let's go now from Tim Scott to Ron
DeSantis Ron DeSantis still has not
successfully received a personality
transplant that is going to help him in
any way I'm going to play some cringe
video for you it's difficult to imagine
a less charismatic Guy The New York
Times wrote up his uh desantis's recent
trip to New Hampshire
DeSantis amps up his retail campaign in
New Hampshire the Florida governor met
with State lawmakers and made the
Standard Diner visit to press flesh with
voters showcasing his more moderate side
he was not showcasing his most moderate
side he bragged about banning pronouns
but more importantly
look at the lack of charisma
it's hard to think of a more awkward and
less charismatic guy here's the Santas
I'll describe this for people not
watching DeSantis enters a diner seems
visibly confused as to how to relate to
people and is kind of told where to
stand and it's
I almost started feeling bad for the guy
because it's almost like when an
introvert is forced into social
situations
ah take a look at this how are you doing
wow look at this Hi how are you guys
good to see you so what do you got go
right over here okay good deal good deal
good deal good deal go hey guys how you
doing oh stand here oh uh yes absolutely
biscuits yes biscuits wow crowded huh
there are people in this establishment
which suggests that business is
transacting how are you doing
smells really good I'll tell you that
you know in these lgbtq smells we're
we're doing away with that in Florida
we're just not gonna do it because it
woke goes to die in Florida and if
anybody tries to slide turkey bacon in
it it is only real bacon none of that
stuff okay I'll tell you that
right now so we'll do it okay
how are you I'm wonderful great to be up
here I love that what's your name Tim
okay
and it's such a little thing but it's
again he just
every detail what's your name oh my my
name's uh uh Jonathan okay
wow what what a guy
stay tuned
are you gonna run stay tuned all right
all right then he also during the same
stop I think or maybe this was a
different Diner looks like he's in a I
don't know where he is same same sort of
thing
um he bragged about how they've banned
pronouns in Florida we just did a bill
in Florida we're not allowing the
pronouns like you can't force these kids
to be choosing they want like a second
grader
listen and if you elect me president I'm
gonna go after adverbs and prepositional
phrases we're gonna just end those like
you wouldn't even believe because these
woke people they want to put and by the
way capitalization on proper nouns we're
gonna get rid of that so fast that
they're gonna get the hell out of
Florida this guy is not ready
he is not ready and it's
constitutionally he just
appealing to moderate voters is what was
reported by the New York Times he
bragged about banning pronouns there is
nothing moderate about that and by the
way if you can say a lot of bad things
about New Hampshire not the state but
what I'm saying there's a lot of
right-wing extremism in New Hampshire
focusing on pronouns I don't even know
is that it's going to do it with New
Hampshire Republicans to be totally
honest so the DeSantis campaign that
still hasn't started looking very very
rough